Donald Trump's criminal trial has been
set for March of 2024 his lawyers are
arguing for a change of venue to federal
court and if that happens it may change
the dates but if indeed Trump's criminal
trial is in March this will be in the
thick of the Republican primary and the
2024 presidential election Republicans
may be close to selecting their nominee
at exactly this time this has the
potential to wreak complete and total
Havoc over Trump's campaign but I
continue to say
if Trump is not charged again arrested
again to the point where it becomes an
impossibility to campaign he is not
dropping out and even though his polling
has been suffering a little bit since
Ron DeSantis announced that he's running
Trump still has the clearest and really
the only direct path to the nomination
of anybody running on the Republican
side is the trial going to bring Trump
down
I genuinely don't think so